so i think the biggest thing
that uh uh i believe and i'm curious to
know what your thoughts are on this is
the challenge was sequencing it wasn't
leaving it was in what sequence do we
leave what goes first what goes last so
do you mind uh shedding sharing some
light on
what was the sequence we took and what
would have been a better strategy of
sequencing and leaving afghanistan
you know for the first time uh you know
i would say that
the entire trust factor in the taliban
in pakistan was the beginning of the
betrayal
you know united states somehow the
diplomats of the united states who were
in the negotiating team led by zalil
khalidza uh you know salman khalifa
himself
were almost convinced by the pakistan
isi the pakistani diplomats and even the
taliban that whatever commitments will
happen in doha will be abided by
whatever uh will be signed will be done
in letter and spirit but let's face it
you know we are talking about taliban i
mean people who have been radicalized in
different seminaries of both pakistan as
well as in afghanistan those people who
are completely illiterate who only
believe in sharia law they do not
believe in any kind of democracy they do
not believe in any kind of education for
the women or equal rights for women so
why did
i
and the negotiating team have a blind
faith over the last two years and i'll
tell you in 2008 almost this entire
process began i think it was in the
middle of 2018 when uh you know zelmay
khalid was appointed formally uh you
know as a spatial onward and earlier i
think i don't remember the exact time
but earlier in 2018 i interviewed salman
khalifa when he was in new delhi and
the entire half in our interview he was
slamming pakistan he said almost that
pakistan was the mothership of terrorism
the lashkar toiba the lashkar-e-jangwi
the jesuit muhammad the haqqani network
and all these terror groups were
helped aided and supported by pakistan
and the world including the united
states including the india and different
other countries need to speak up need to
have a cohesive vision and uh some kind
of a cooperation against these
pakistan-sponsored terrorists
and
to the contrary within a few months we
see a different tune all together where
zalel salman khalid is in bed with uh
you know pakistan almost convinced at
every step and being almost an envoy of
pakistan in the united states telling
them that we need to trust them we need
to be completely convinced that they
will abide by whatever happens now what
happened
taliban said that they will not uh you
know kill innocents they said the
suicide bombings will stop they said the
americans will also not be targeted but
what happened in reality
we had targeted attacks and
assassinations taking place not just in
kabul but all across afghanistan we had
not just the nds and the and dsf of the
afghan army being attacked but we also
had targeted attacks at afghan
university american university in kabul
at hospitals emergency services in
government buildings ministry of
interior
and several other you know important
buildings uh in kabul and elsewhere so
where did the taliban cooperate with the
united states it did not and still the
united states had only one thing in mind
that we have to somehow leave and vacate
because joe biden has been always of the
view that you know we should not have
boots on ground we are not there to you
know tackle the internal dynamics of
afghanistan
we are not there to have a democratic
government but we are there to in fact
you know launch an attack on al qaeda
perhaps it ended when osama bin laden
was killed and in fact he was found in
pakistan so
the entire exit strategy collapsed you
know that is when uh you know when the
trust factor was not there when of
course uh any kind of a rapport that was
built up in reality wasn't there i mean
any of the demands of the united states
or the negotiated team were not being
fulfilled then how did uh the us really
trust taliban on the other hand the
afghan government beat ashraf ghani beat
amarula saleh beat any of their you know
ambassadors to the u.n or to the u.s or
others or even karzai for that matter
and to an extent even abdul abdullah if
all of them were not in page on the same
page with the doha agreement
then how did you dare to announce a
timeline abide by the timeline and
actually fulfill that promise
given to the taliban and it's not just
spider trump did the same you know trump
and biden
equally shoulder the responsibility of
abandoning the innocent afghans and what
we have seen over the last one month or
a little more is just a teaser of what
the taliban is really going to do over
the last many months now and it's not
just the question patrick of afghanistan
is the question of the entire regional
security
i mean
how much the other terror groups
the islamist radical sunni terrorist
groups will get emboldened with the fact
that here is a sharia law that has been
applied completely in afghanistan we
have a safe shelter we can run terror
camps we can have a hiding space there
and what kind of a defeat that united
states has faced because that is what is
the chatter i've been monitoring the
dark web where not just the al-qaeda the
isis and other terror groups are active
and they feel emboldened they see this
as a
defeat of the united states and
afghanistan and the hell will break
loose now because you know there are two
countries that are completely focused on
diplomatically and otherwise supporting
the taliban one is pakistan obviously
and second of course is china
now china i don't know how they will do
this how they will be the next uh you
know so-called superpower to actually
enter afghanistan or whether they will
because it is only going to be a one-way
investment
uh
is is it's going to be a very tricky
affair it's going to be a very good
chance so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you